depuis le 11 mai date du déconfinement
la vie sportive reprend partiellement
ses droits dans les yvelines et golfeurs
peuvent de nouveau tapé la balle blanche
sur la vingtaine de golf du département
sur le parcours plus de banc ni de
poubelles un protocole sanitaire est
également mise en place pour les joueurs
on ne peut pas toucher le drapeau donc
on a mis en place des systèmes pour que
la balle ne retombe pas complètement
dans le trou pour que les gens puissent
enlever sans toucher le drapeau ni le
trou leurs balles de golf il n'y a pas
de râteau sur le parcours donc dans les
obstacles les bunkers ils sont toujours
en jeu mais on demande aux gens de
ratisser en fête avec leurs pieds ou
avec un club de golf pour penser au
suivant les parties de tennis sont
également autorisés seulement simple sur
les courts totalement découvert dans les
yvelines 90 clubs sur 130 structures ont
rouvert mais ils sont tous soumis à un
protocole très strict les portes restent
ouvertes les bancs et chaises sont
désinfectés et les joueurs doivent
s'engager à suivre les procédures
chaque joueur doit arriver déjà en tenue
arrivé un petit peu juste au moment de
la réservation puisque les réservations
doivent se faire en ligne exclusivement
et puis chaque jour doit arriver
également avec ses balles et ses balles
doivent être marquées par un symbole qui
le choisissent eux mêmes dans la mesure
où ensuite
un joueur doit de deux touchés avec la
main que ses propres balles en plus de
ces deux sports dans les yvelines vous
pouvez également pratiquer la course à
pied l'équitation la marche sportive le
cyclisme sur route en respectant une
distance minimum de dix mètres entre
deux personnes